>>Peggy: The teacher doesn't just
throw control to the students
and say, "Let me know
what you figure out."
She really has to plan ahead of
time, she has to figure out how
to group the students so that
they're the most productive.
She has to scaffold their work,
so she provides hints or clues
or templates, worksheets
is necessary,
to kinda show them what
they need to do first,
what they might consider doing next.
She has to teach them
how to work together.
Teamwork is not something
that comes naturally,
especially for younger students.
They really need to
learn how to do that.
>>Sheela: So we would have a
anchor or a set of expectations
about what kind of language
would be used, what the roles
and responsibilities are for
each person in that group.
And what are the processes for asking
further questions or clarification?
>>Student: So you start with one
trail mix and give out stickers.
I'll do two trail mixes.
Bryce does the questions and
then you do the other things.
>>Student: I do the
sticker charge thing.
>>Liza: So when students are working
on projects in different groups,
it's difficult to get
to all of them at once,
and they may really need you.
So my first strategy for
that is teaching a child how
to use each other, teaching
them how to talk to one another,
and so here we call
it accountable talk.
So what are ways that you talk
with each other when you disagree?
How do you do that in a respectful
manner, to continue to collaborate
with each other and
keep the project moving?
Also, I do a lot of
tabletop directions,
if I have short directions that they
need to get through or a checklist
or an agenda, they have to get
through so many things by the end
of the day or the end of the week,
instead of raising their hand
and asking me and I have
to run back and forth,
it's right there in front of them.
>>Student: Oh, that makes sense.
>>Teacher: So what's this
lake potentially used for?
>>Sheela: So it's really
the art of facilitation.
The teacher would not be at the front
of the room directing instruction,
but instead she is
choreographing instruction.
So she's like a conductor and she
would go to all the different tables
and groups to ensure that each
group is working in harmony
to achieve that goal at the end.